okay let's go to our next caller from
the six one eight area code caller from
six one eight welcome to the program
tell us who you are
hi David I'm Gary Gary go ahead what's
on your mind today hi I was uh wanted to
say that never in a thousand years would
I have thought the Republicans would be
attacking the FBI the way they have and
if you think there will be some sort of
repository repercussions for that on
their end for just sort of shaming them
and bashing them the way they have been
yeah
Gary let me take this opportunity to
congratulate you because you've called
in with just a beautiful phone
connection we're clearly not on
speakerphone you're just coming through
so well that you're really if all
callers were like you we would all be
much better off so first thanks for that
Gary well thank you very much all right
the real way that there will be
repercussions
to the Republican Party for what's
effectively a war with the FBI in the
intelligence community is the
repercussion of us voting them out in
nine months and then again in two years
and nine months those are going to be
the repercussions if we're waiting
around for there to be any other kind of
repercussions for the Republican Party
taking on the FBI almost as if it's some
kind of hostile actor it's going to be
just voting them out and that's why I
think it's important for us to focus on
the midterms and and really boat we've
just we need voter turnout to be high
yeah I agree
all right hope you're right Gary thank
you very much appreciate the call all
right thank you Dave pleasure let's take
a quick break and we will be back with
more of your phone calls right after
this